bullet cat podcast special guest in here
my guy
j stone what up what up what's cracking
my guys good to see you again man we
back yeah
uh the definition of sacrifice yeah
this is like uh what how many projects
have you dropped in this series where
you know i feel like we have the
definition of loyalty
definition of pain and now we're at the
definition of sacrifice now we have the
definition of sacrifice yeah so it's
like the trilogy of the series that i'm
dropping you know what i'm saying and
yeah here we go again
yeah i mean and it's as you've been i
told you man you've been because i feel
like we've gotten all three projects
relatively in a small amount of time
yeah it's been about like in the last
two years in the last two yeah going on
three yeah that's crazy i thought about
that [ __ ] too i'm like damn like
is it too soon or should i you know what
i'm saying but like nah cause you know
most artists you know even your favorite
artist you know what i'm saying they
give you a classic album each year yeah
and they don't let a year go by that's
how jay-z used to be back in the day
every summer exactly exactly or he hit
you before the year you know what i'm
saying
so
yeah plus for you being independent and
owning all of your music it's uh it it's
for your business model the more music
you put out the better it is right oh
yeah it's way better you know what i'm
saying i'm i'm i'm i'm so used to the
grind now like then the reviews the
reviews is cool mm-hmm you feel me but
if i get stuck on that i'm gonna be
chasing that um you said my like
critical like response to your [ __ ] yeah
just all that yeah exactly you know what
i'm saying i feel like um
you're
very much
outside of the industry as you possibly
can be like i feel like you're on your
mission
and whoever wants to [ __ ] with you is
gonna [ __ ] with you but you're very much
like
you got the blinders on yeah and your
tunnel vision you got your tunnel vision
and i don't i feel like you know
i don't feel like you're like you really
deal with a lot of the industry [ __ ]
like nah man you gotta you gotta you
gotta it's it's a balance
it's really a balance you know what i'm
saying yeah so you know but it's a lot
of [ __ ] i do [ __ ] with industry
you know what i'm saying that [ __ ] with
me of course i mean yeah but those are
like real genuine relationships like i
saw you out i saw you out in uh for you
know shout out to trey uh shout out to
trey day yeah um you know obviously this
record with dolph i'm assuming that that
came from a genuine place as well yeah
we went to the studio and did that like
we we didn't do no email [ __ ] like we
actually did that yeah kind of explain
um you know obviously rest in peace to
dolph i'm assuming this is a record that
you've had for a long time yeah um how
long ago was it recorded um
like two years ago wow yeah we recorded
like
20 20.
you know what i'm saying we used to just
chop it up you know i'm saying he'll
call me out facetime and we'll facetime
each other every other week or some [ __ ]
like yeah i mean he was the best man
yeah
how like was it like a little bit
difficult getting the record cleared
without him being here i mean because we
do know his people
are very solid and they you know man
yeah i had to go through some channels i
had to go through
had to go through some channels you know
what i'm saying managers record label
you know i'm saying legal teams you know
what i'm saying they all they all know
who i am you feel me yeah i did it
myself i made them phone calls myself
you know what i'm saying i didn't send
nobody to do that you know what i'm
saying yeah how like how how big would
you describe your
like music team to be i got a team
definitely i got a team but sometimes
you know i'd be wanting to make the
calls myself you feel me they hit
different that way yeah just hit
different that way you feel me and then
after that you know what i'm saying i
put up with my team and then my team
would take care of the rest you know
what i'm saying yeah it's it's
definitely um
i even feel like i just had an artist
who his pr person was hitting me and i
just faced him i'm like hey dude why the
[ __ ] you got some random ass
[ __ ] i don't know hit me up to
come on my show when you did because
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying like i
mean i could have did that too you feel
me because i got a new pr now you feel
me but it's like i mean
ain't no sense of having him hit you
when i can do that myself you feel me
sometimes but sometimes you say the
headache though well that and like also
like this way i look at it
if your your album's coming out you're
at a level where pr is
helpful but like i feel like
you're kind of paying the pr person to
bridge you from
into new
media situations you couldn't get onto
yourself exactly for sure you know yeah
uh who else is on the project i know you
sent me the album like a little while
ago i didn't get to run through it so
who else on the album we got uh i got
jadakiss i got a
styles
some [ __ ] east coast hitters yeah
yeah you got them both on the same
record nah nah nah i almost did almost
did but it was it was just best that i
got one with oh jada so it's you know
it's legendary you feel me what up y'all
got to stop the interview real quick to
tell you about our good folks over at
blue chew now fellas if you're out there
and you're suffering from a little bit
of that ed erectile dysfunction it's
totally normal it happens you could be
stressed out at work you could be
just having anxiety in life and uh you
know your dick is not up to par well
guess what that's where blue chew comes
in because blue chew
has the same active ingredients as
viagra and escialis and check this out
it's a straight online prescription
service you do not have to go to the
doctor's office you don't have to go
have any like weird awkward
conversations about why your dick isn't
working with a stranger no what you do
is you go to bluechew.com
use the promo code bootleg and you'll
get your first month for free that's
right first month for free all you do is
pay five dollars shipping all right and
when i tell you that bluetooth it hits
all right you will uh
you'll be [ __ ] like you never [ __ ]
before let's just say that shout out to
uh blue chew one more time get your
first month free use the promo code
bootleg bluechew.com it comes right to
your door in discrete packaging open it
up it's in a chewable form and it is
that [ __ ] to fight ed so go to
bluetooth.com asap and use that promo
code bootleg and try it for a month for
free consider yourself a pretty heavily
like influenced by the east coast like
type of rapper yeah for sure i mean you
know that's you know we grew up on that
[ __ ] you feel what i'm saying so that's
just what it is you feel me in my lyrics
you feel me i just i feel it when i
listen to you i feel like you're just
like you're very like you're lyrical as
[ __ ] so yeah that makes sense yeah cause
at a point in time [ __ ] i'm pretty sure
they thought the west coast didn't have
lyrics like that you feel me i think at
a point in time that might have been the
case yeah you feel me so i always want
to be one of the [ __ ]
that you know when you listen to
somebody from the west you know what i'm
saying like me you'll be like yeah that
[ __ ] got lyrics he ain't just he ain't
just right
jaden styles who else golf dolph i got
lumedy on there wow yeah
oh gee
wow yeah shout out to her shout out to
illuminati that's the home girl for
shows okay
are those the four are there anymore no
i got more i got mozzie on there you
feel me hell gang yeah hell gang mozzie
we got some [ __ ] going you feel me
yeah damn that's so you got a that's a
hell of a lineup yeah hell of lana and i
got k camp on my [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying we got one for the ladies
camp is um historically slept on yeah
his hooks are crazy he crap he could
sing
he'd do the r b [ __ ] he could do the
lady [ __ ] yeah all of that yeah for sure
so you know i thought i thought about
bringing that r b rap yeah [ __ ] back you
found what i'm saying like you remember
how you used to hear you know what i'm
saying a certain r b song you hear
you'll hear the first verse and then you
hear some more r b then you hear another
rap versus yeah you feel me yeah like
fabulous used to do it yeah obviously
john rules yeah nelly having joints
nah for sure yeah so i just thought i'd
do something different because my last
project i didn't cater to the women none
right
right got to give them something yeah
hell yeah cause they be at the shows and
[ __ ] i'm like damn i ain't got too much
for them so now
yeah i got like four full records for
the females on this joint so when you
send kiss and styles a record
well first of all was it that was that
the case or were you guys in together
nah we we sent we sent the records do
you
send them your verse
so look this was yeah all right do you
wait until you get their verse back so
you know how crazy you got now nah nah
nah nah they gon they gonna look you
gotta rock to what i already got you
gotta rock i'm gonna bring you tomorrow
okay okay i ain't gonna change nothing
even if you go crazy i'm not gonna be
like uh so they got to hear your verse
yeah okay okay okay yeah you feel me i
was gonna put jade on the one with
styles
you know what i'm saying and you know a
few weeks went by and i'm like
you know
i give a [ __ ] two weeks you know what
i'm saying you know i hit that line you
feel me and
[ __ ]
i figured it probably was the record i
don't know i'm like all right let me
just send them this one though yeah i'm
like i think you'll go crazy with me in
this one with swears you feel me and
that [ __ ] sent that [ __ ] back the next
day wait swiss produced this record yeah
swiss produced a record with me and
jaden
what yeah
this is crazy yeah
kudos to you jay because you're doing
some real you're doing some real major
ass [ __ ] ryan i've been grinding i'm a
fan of hip-hop you feel me like even
when i was a kid i always felt like
one day i was gonna be here
you feel me so it's good to like you
know what i'm saying
exchange bars with the greats
that's crazy yeah a swiss beats record
with kiss on it come on man squares on
the hook
stop playing swears on the hook you feel
me that's crazy how the hell did you end
up linking with swiss beats
uh
[ __ ] man going to the studio with uh
going to the studio with x
pulling up on x
you know what i'm saying
yeah when he was working on the album
and i was going to go pull up on x
because
you know it's been a minute
you know so i put up to the studio as
soon as i walked in that [ __ ] swizz was
like
hey
he nice right there you feel me just put
me on the spot in front of everybody you
know what i'm saying
d was there why was there rough riders
all they needed
yeah they were they always in the
building you feel me put the spot on me
feel me so
that's where it started
so he put the did he put the spotlight
on you like to [ __ ] rap on the spot
nah just you know he was just like he
didn't even give me time to shake
nobody's hand and greet nobody he like
oh yeah that [ __ ] nice right there but
he already knew exactly who you were
yeah that's a [ __ ] i've seen swears like
in my early days like
10 years ago you know what i'm saying
when i first was doing this music [ __ ]
yeah we're not first doing his music
[ __ ] but when i came home it got serious
yeah that's crazy man all right well
listen you're being nonchalant about
some of the [ __ ] going on in your album
you're like yeah swiss is on it it's a
big [ __ ] deal man yeah it is bro it
is you know what i'm saying i'm i'm i'm
humbly aggressive about this [ __ ] though
okay so we got mozzy lemony uh
styles kiss
dolph anybody else yeah we got a i got
an elam on my [ __ ] i don't even know who
that is
neelam yeah yeah see i'm i'm not hip
yeah that's cool you're gonna be here i
i i'm looking forward to it yeah she
dope she's got a phone call hold me down
singer
singer and rap okay yeah
so you gotta man i i feel like what
you're doing is like
somehow not being appreciated enough
because i feel like you're doing like
you're doing [ __ ] rappers with major
deals aren't doing you're making money
they're not making exactly they're
driving the cars they can't afford to
drive exactly bro i'm like what the [ __ ]
is going on you feel me but it's cool
though cause
you know
they gonna catch it later bro they might
not catch it now
cause it's like that for everybody
sometimes you know [ __ ] might need a
just a full 10 year run i know my 10th
year run yet you know what i'm saying a
lot of [ __ ] got their 10th year run
and look at them now you know what i'm
saying
i feel like um
you just gotta keep that blinder shake
everything just keep yeah everybody
it'll come to you bro yeah don't worry
about going to it yeah
you and davey still doing a project
together for sure it's almost done we're
gonna go on tour together i probably
shouldn't have said that but
i don't know what i'm saying that's
that's that's what it is you feel me for
sure that's big man yeah i wanna know
your thoughts on when you first saw
kendrick's video the heart part five
man
amazing number one you know what i'm
saying i damn near i damn nearly dropped
a tear
you know what i'm saying that [ __ ] was
just when it got to nip part you feel me
it was just
that [ __ ] was crazy the movement the
gestures everything the mannerism
everything like that [ __ ] it should hit
different
you know what i'm saying definitely it
was uh words just just what he was
saying like it was you know what i'm
saying some real impacted
[ __ ]
do you uh cause when i saw that i was
like okay well obviously this is a
powerful moment first of all it's the
first
music we've heard from kendrick in five
years five years you know what i'm
saying it's the first
it's the first look we get from you know
what i'm saying the first sound we get
from and then for him to
do that was to me like
it's that's a hard thing to do
without it
like it just it i only i feel like only
kendra could have did that yeah you know
what i mean yeah cause i think if
somebody else would have did that
yeah people would have looked at him
like crazy yeah
do you do you happen to know if like he
ran that by like sam or anybody before
it came out or was it kind of like did
everyone hear it when everyone heard it
nah
i mean
[ __ ] like that come from the heart you
know what i'm saying i don't think you
gotta you know what i'm saying run [ __ ]
like that by the team especially you
being kendrick and we you know i'm
saying we [ __ ] with you of course with
the team you home team your family
you feel me um
yeah i think that's something just
straight from the heart you feel me like
i ain't even gonna let nobody even know
i'm doing it y'all gonna see it when
y'all see it yeah yeah yeah it was it
was powerful dude yeah it was crazy
because i also feel like
when that happened you know we didn't
get to hear from kendrick in the turn
like kendrick
we i mean we've been waiting five years
right yeah so when we lost nip man like
you know when we think of la we think a
nip and we think of kendrick yeah
exactly and to like finally kind of
get to hear him
you know put his thoughts in into
anything about just any any yeah but
just that loss like you know it's just
man it's just great it was crazy like
you said it was some real emotional [ __ ]
yeah it was trippy at first i looked at
it i'm like
you know what i'm saying just going
through all the different faces not even
just with nip just yeah kobe uh
just all of it yeah yeah
super crazy man
um let's talk about like
you obviously are very much active as an
artist but i do feel like you have some
ceo [ __ ] in you are you signing artists
are you
gonna be like
doing the label thing i know you that's
definitely something i'm gonna do uh
i'm gonna drop this mixtape with drama
there's a dramatic yes i shouldn't even
be listening i noticed anything
definitely so you got a gangster girls
coming yeah man
yeah i'm too ahead of my time i think
i'm ahead of myself you feel me
for real how the hell okay so
shout out to drama yes it's the most
legendary mixtape series of all time
my guy just got a grammy off of uh
tyler hosting tyler the creator's outfit
yeah
uh
are you done with the project is the
gangster girls done yes no we just
getting started i'm about to go i'm
about to go to the a
uh and tap in
uh next week and finish up you're gonna
go to uh have you been his uh have you
been a generation now years ago yeah
it's new they moved no no i know i need
to come to the new spot yeah uh are you
gonna do
because the one thing that's tricky
about the mixtape game now
is if you take other people's beats you
might not be able to put it on spotify
and it's a thing i'm i'm i'm i'm i'm
doing this [ __ ] with my producers all
original [ __ ] from my label and my
artist so you're going to be able to
actually
put it out on itunes and spotify that's
good yeah legendary got to you feel me
gotta let the world hear you from me
because i think the legendary mixtapes
are putting it on that pith only that
[ __ ] cool but it's like yeah but no
one's i mean shout out to that piff but
like it's
people it's like people listening to
music everywhere like too many different
places so i just can't just have it just
stuck there yeah no they're not for sure
and if we think of the crazy og mixtapes
cushion orange juice yeah classic all
the wrist that was all that was all
original production yeah
yeah yeah yeah that i mean a lot of a
lot of mixtapes could have been albums
you know what i'm saying i think there
was albums but we just didn't know it
yet we didn't know yet yeah just the
error was mixtape so he was calling the
mixtapes you know what i'm saying 100 it
was a weird error because it was the
blog era yeah it was yeah you feel me
and it was popping you drop a mixtape
and you know you go crazy go on tour go
on tour off of me i'm like off of a free
project performing mixtapes something
like songs he did off of wayne exactly
joints you feel me and the crowd love it
like everywhere even big tours like you
know i'm saying he performing that song
hey we got to stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our good folks
at odd socks listen the most comfortable
socks in the entire world i promise you
are these odd socks basics right here
now i like the uh the uh high joints the
whites or the blacks
we're very inclusive at the bootleg head
podcast love the blacks and the whites
of odd socks of course um but they also
got the crazy licenses they got ninja
turtles they got a [ __ ] scarface
breaking bad socks which i just
rewatched amazing and their underwear
the best man i was just talking to
somebody about how fire the odd socks
draws are because the waistband don't
fold they're just comfy as hell so go to
odd
socksofficial.com you see the website
spell it that same way and use the promo
code bootleg kev all one word together
and you'll get 20
off from our presenting sponsors our
family at odd socks it's all that's on
my ass and feet ladies and gentlemen so
we'll get you some odd socks let's get
back to the interview that's crazy bro
yeah that's crazy so the album's coming
out june 15th june 15th yeah june 15th
we're gonna get the project
um lots of big features
davies collab project coming yeah tour
yeah
gangsta grills coming yeah
so much i wanted to ask you i had t-rel
up here and i saw you went up to no
jumper and did an interview with him
can you for people who aren't aware as
to why that was a big deal man because
there might be people who are watching
this who aren't from l.a who aren't hip
to the politics of la so why was that
such a big deal that you and t rail sat
with each other man number one shout out
to t real man great guy yeah
real 100 dude solid dude you feel me
you know i feel like you know we come
from the same [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying you know south central l.a you
know what i'm saying the hoods the you
know what i'm saying going to jail
you know so it's like
it at some point you know what i'm
saying you gotta you gotta you gotta
show the young [ __ ] that you know i'm
saying we can elevate we can grow
you know what i'm saying is something
beyond just you know what i'm saying
doing that we can't get do business
together [ __ ] can't get money together
you know what i'm saying so yeah because
your guys neighborhoods obviously don't
get along it's probably the
most notorious disagreement in la
in the la street politics like
so like i just thought that that was
dope man because i do feel like
eventually somebody's gotta
you know
show everybody that yeah somebody gotta
do it you feel me just because based on
the politics you know what i'm saying
you know how la is like oh you ain't
supposed to do this supposedly holly
right there you supposed to talk to your
name supposed to kick it with them
you feel me but you your own man at the
end of the day like you feel me and my
homies
they [ __ ] with that damn they ain't
against it they wasn't opposed to it you
know what i'm saying [ __ ] can't be
like oh [ __ ] you wouldn't do it that
way for me it don't work like that
do you think that there's like because i
think when nip passed obviously um
everybody uh
when big you set up uh where everybody
had marched over there together
which was a big deal
um
but
what do you think is like the key in
breaking the
cycle because it's hard to tell people
i think it got to be more of that right
there what you just said it can't just
be
done just only on
you know i'm saying just one day it got
to be done multiple times you feel me
they gotta they got they gotta they
gotta get used to being with each other
being around each other and not doing
[ __ ] you know yeah man
because
i mean it was good to see people that i
know
that
you know i'm saying then probably
wouldn't even be with each other be or
stand around each other you know what
i'm saying next to each other so you
know i think more of it
i think you know what i'm saying [ __ ]
will get the point yeah i just think
like
when there's like such a
i always say you can't tell people how
to react to certain [ __ ] right so if
somebody
you know once upon a time maybe took
your cousin's life or your brother's
life yeah i can't tell anybody how to
react to that but like eventually it's
like
you would hope one day the cycle because
it's just every time a reaction happens
to an action yeah it just resets the
whole thing yeah exactly and sometimes
you'd be thinking like it ain't gonna
stop like it's never ending
but i mean you know
somebody somebody got to do it it can be
done i believe it can be done you know
what i'm saying that's why i thought it
was dope to see you guys sit together
man because t-rel's a great guy you're a
great guy yeah and it's like some real
leadership [ __ ] to like show everybody
else yeah that is possible exactly yeah
somebody else gonna watch that and you
know what i'm saying they might be
feeling a
certain way about another situation they
you know i'm saying they might be like
oh all right well i can do it over here
was there ever any a situation
where you
on the music side
where
maybe you wanted to work with somebody
or
somebody wanted to work with you but
y'all just couldn't make it happen just
because of the politics uh
nah i mean i would say like [ __ ] like
211 or schoolboy q but like
i mean we never let the hood [ __ ]
like get in the way of that [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying we always want to
do records with each other and [ __ ] like
that you fit me but it's just you know
we never did it but 211's a great guy
yeah like great guy i seen him in my
hood i see him in i'm saying he see me
in his hood you feel me and q and q is
an amazing guy he's the funniest he's
the funniest rapper exactly no no he's
one yeah yeah he says some crazy [ __ ]
though yeah that's like that's the main
guy i always think about like man if you
cue a nip record you know what i mean
like certain [ __ ] like that that like
you know would have been crazy but like
obviously you know but people for who
aren't from here don't understand that
kind of [ __ ] so i think they don't cause
like
everybody everybo everybody ain't wit
getting money everybody ain't with the
music [ __ ] it's some [ __ ] that's just
you know what i'm saying they don't give
a [ __ ] about none of that yeah yeah that
makes sense you know what i'm saying and
that's crazy you feel me that's crazy
but they gotta they gotta live life they
gotta explore a little bit you feel me i
mean i was young before i remember i
didn't give a [ __ ] about getting money
right right you were you used to be that
guy yeah exactly so you had to go yeah i
mean but you you know you're gone man
me levels to it indeed bro well i
appreciate you coming through man thanks
for having me man always we got the
freestyle we're about to do so that's
gonna be a separate youtube video so go
check that [ __ ] out the album the
definition of sacrifice is this the
final in the is this gonna be a trilogy
not nah it's gonna be
one more i got one more definition of
success i like that that's how you end
it yeah i like it but you know you know
that was that was that was that was nip
idea you know what i'm saying me and
that was texting each other i had sent
them and i sent them but i gave them my
cd
with like some songs on there from the
definition of loyalty yeah and that's
when he text me like definition of
loyalty that's the name of your album
you know what i'm saying then he kept
texting like your next album should be
definition of sacrifice definition of
pain definition of that's hard success
you feel me
and i'm like and here we are there it is
there's the four
there it is right there you feel me so
i i ain't gonna stop there it is man j
stone go get the album appreciate you
bro yeah let's go man perfect